I spent on the recommended supplement protocol for about two weeks and is experiencing diarrhea.
It was recommended that we discontinue all supplements and then slowly introduce them to determine
the source. What's the best way to do this? She's also drinking lemon water regularly. Could that be
causing the diarrhea not the supplements? Well the lemon water could be, but if she was drinking lemon water
before this, then I would say probably not. But if your answer to that question would be,
well, yeah, she actually just started drinking lemon water at the same time. Well, maybe,
maybe. So when you have an adverse reaction, and I would say having diarrhea as an adverse reaction
to anything, you've got to discontinue what you changed when this new symptoms started.
So you got to look back and tell you if the best you could do and say, well, yeah, it was right when
we started all this. Okay, then you just got to take everything out and go back on one of the time,
give it three, take everything out and tell her diarrhea goes away and then go back on one of the time.
Yep, that didn't cause it. Let's go back on this one. That didn't cause it. If you need help on which
is the most important to go back on. First, I will help you with that. So just contact me. But you just
got it. It's a process of elimination. This isn't uncommon with people, especially if we're a little
bit older, that our system can just want to flush. It's just irritating our system and we're just not
absorbing well. And honestly, it might actually be that the, it might not be the nutrient in the pill.
It might be the capsule. That could be an irritant. I've had that happen where people would just
open up the capsule and put it there smoothie and then they did everything problems. So we just got
to figure that out.